this shows you that bones are literally
different wait like you see what's going
on here big bone something does uh never
mind that's actually a gorilla on the
right side sorry I was going to say I'm
pretty sure that's a a giant ape wait a
second I'm not big boned I'm just fat
yeah big boned isn't real that's not a
real situation yeah people have
different metabolism at the very least
yeah that's true people have different
body chemistry but if you're at of shape
you can't you can't blame it on your
bones you're out of shape because it's
your that's your body it's your meat and
your muscles and your fat and there's no
there's no excuse